44 they spent most of last year talking
about 40 for they spent a decent amount
of today is talking about both fallout 4
and fallout shelter and in a weird way
the kind of turning fallout 4 into
fallout shelter and turning fallout
shelter in 24 hour for let's talk about
the fallout 4 stuff first of all you can
have build shelters and run experiments
yeah yeah I saw yea votes and also put
like so this is actually the first thing
they showed was the contraptions
workshop which is what we talked about
in the pre-show that was leaked and I'm
not that poor Xbox user had their cantle
heaters and or shut off so this is weird
cuz it's like something your belt so I'm
sort of rude goldberg machine you're
saying look that's pretty funny oh my
god and then they went into the next
section we showed off you straight up
building falls which is what you do in
fallout shelter yeah you build the vault
and then you fill it with people and you
make them do things and you can do you
could experiment on your on your your
vault oh can you make them have like two
rocks you know I almost had some down
there at two stallions male stallions
like you have in your fallout shelter
impregnating all of the female bosom
listen I I got some real heist at babies
after that they were it was worth it it
was totally worth it maybe mod support
for that sort of see interesting could
you just be calling me building anything
fallout shelter in fallout but now
they're adding their they added quests
and right yes of the fallout shelter
stuff then is that you can now leave the
vols had to go on quests you can meet up
with different volts Weller's like bring
them in but you actually find them now
there's like buildings what the one
thing you see was are like a room like a
red rocket kind of thing do they like
went into another another building or
another area and like moving around in
it um ya know those two things two games
are converging there's rice to morph
into the same kind of I mean that's fine
they send yeah we could do that before
we can actually go along with them was
that a husky oh my god new locations and
new combat stuff in as well pence it's
rad scorpions all up in your grill oh
yeah new combat system
as well I'm gonna pay out advice is that
the is that the Pope I don't know it's
weird but now I'm also coming to pc yeah
real weird maybe fall I for is calling
to mobile I don't know it's just hopping
next month as well so coming to VR it is
right almost got it let's talk about